and it's blue Margo Margo time for a
Mario sandwich I have my very own Margo
sandwich I got the happy Mago cup which
looks really nice on that but it's not
available in the UK there is an email
dough in the video description where you
can actually email your protest if
you're from the UK it's Paper Towns
oh it's so good maybe if I rub it
on my face I'll live forever I'm not one
to cry for fictional characters and
events but I didn't cry at the end of
this book which doesn't mean the ending
is unhappy still good so there's this
theory that every single piece of
literature can be said to follow one of
these plots when the best things about
paper towels is that it follows all
three if you're a knit student then this
is a word that you've probably heard
bandied about some of the reasons where
this is so good because John manages to
make you laugh one page and then have
your eyes bursting with tears on the
next page nothing again on the next page
and then you just find yourself
completely drawn into this fabulous book
that you absolutely must read I love
this book a whole lot when I read it I
can hear John Green telling me a story I
wanted to read more I wanted it to be
this wide this book and other John Green
books actually have kind of restored my
interest in literature you should buy it
this comes from the perspective of
someone who doesn't have a lot of money
to spend I mean I cut my own hair with
safety scissors last night the book is
chock-full of really interesting ideas
that really help you again said John's
head whoever I roll has to bake a cake
in celebration of the release of Paper
Towns
[Music]
I can't wait for Paper Towns that's
amazing and everyone out there should
read it I'm really really excited that
Paper Towns is finally coming out and
that everyone finally gets to experience
the wonderfulness that is John Green's
third book absolute favorite thing about
Paper Towns was how it dealt with such
big important ideas without sounding
lofty or condescending
it had the absolutely perfect mix of
Walt Whitman and penis jokes
also John Green must be some kind of
master balance because one of the other
reasons that I thought Paper Towns was
so fantastic was that it packed so much
stuff into it without making you feel
overwhelmed or like he's trying to cram
something down your throat it's easily
the best book that I have read this week
you should be like super proud of what
you've accomplished nerdfighters and
readers everywhere are really going to
enjoy it
best wishes I haven't counted in a while
but the last time I did it had about 150
books and about 4 of them were not in a
science fiction or fantasy setting and
so John Green's Paper Towns
is not the kind of book that I would
usually read or get it's kind of a
novelty thing you know like you watch
these videos so you kind of feel like
you know the guy and so reading this
it's like reading a book that your
friend wrote except as it turns out a
really freaking good book I mean what
starts as this really light-hearted
quite funny teenager erupts and really
suddenly and awesomely transitions in
your life is really serious look at like
how we see other people I was expecting
like that doesn't have a sword or an
explosion in it I cried in the end I
mean I cried in anemic faith as well but
it's gotta count
Paper Towns dftb PT BJP so much and why
I like John Green as an author is
because he always writes to his smartest
audience he doesn't assume that just
because it's teenagers reading it that
they're gonna be dumb and they can't
understand anything but how many
one-liners are there in this book I was
sitting here in my living room just
reading alone
my man cat was here and I was just
cracking up and my cat was looking at me
like what the heck are you laughing at
why are you making so much noise lady
what you doing I'm like I'm reading
Paper Towns it's hilarious
[Music]
you